[Music]
they're the greatest stories ever told
[Music]
here Oh show us we don't need to be
perfect to do what's right it's not
about living without fear but facing
injustice it's not about being powerful
but finding your calling when you least
expect it they show us it's okay to be
vulnerable you matter how tough you are
because even though they're heroes
there's still human
[Music]
discover the greatest stories ever told
only on Netflix looks like I got here
just the time the contact at the mayor's
office he's ready how soon can we begin
three months then we move to the final
phase that won't work not anymore we
need to move faster we are greeted this
plan it makes sense made sense took
great efforts to arrange this if we
speed the process it will not be quiet
I'm aware I will inform the others good
send my regards when you do math you I
want to talk frankly where's this other
life feel that it's your heart still
with it or is your heart will the one
who walked through it by your side
Elektra yeah I do miss her
but I know that the things she brought
out of me were wrong from what you've
told me about her I think she'd be happy
about how well you're doing maybe or
maybe she'd tell me I'm abandoning that
life I'm with it for memory they're not
a band then he'll Elektra you don't have
it in you what you're doing
we call that moving on predatory is a
place for the dead Matthew not the
living there's nothing wrong with
letting people go she'll find her peace
I pray you find yours as well the thing
about war is it only works if both sides
to leave they're the good guys the truth
is we're not so different we fight to
get back what was once ours
[Music]
but in the end and this is the end it's
just a city you'll get used to watching
them fall like we're safe for now we
need to figure out our next vote felt
there's no next move and there is no we
what is that we're not here to eat those
pork not on the shrimp oh this guy's got
pork god you're weird
I'm not looking for Super Friends that
doesn't matter can't fight these people
not even with whatever it is your hand
can do it's cheap it's not they're
hunting our friends our families and I'm
not gonna stop there
[Music]
more guesses coming
and the only thing keeping Manhattan for
crumble into a pile of dust as the four
of you the wars are New York it's over
not yet
[Music]
eyes ears performs
I can see you've formed a kind of odd
I promise he was temporary
by Crom they will disappoint
Jessica like you're not
go out there together
we found each other I'm not hugging you
[Music]
it's been a long week
[Music]
[Applause]
who knows
and and the reason is for that is
because we needed to find somebody that
could take on all these guys
she doesn't require any introduction
anywhere she goes in the world she will
be joining the defenders cast ladies and
gentlemen I am it is my distinct
pleasure to introduce mr. corny
[Applause]
[Music]
you have interrupted a citywide
investigation you stole evidence from my
crime scene and you got my one lead
killed I was trying to help him but you
didn't jealous stop talking who the hell
are you
My name is Matthew Murdock I'm your
attorney
[Music]
how does being harlem's hero allow you
to live an actual life right now I just
want to help people I think there's
something that you need to meet who are
you
who are you how come you can't be hurt
what's the deal with that fist
I'm the immortal iron fist
you won't you're on the same side
you for the devil of Hell's Kitchen the
smartass detective got a problem the
righteous X Cohen and the kid with the
glowing fish the war for New York is
here
[Music]
so get your [ __ ] together more
connections you have
we'll be - Frankie
[Music]
or scarf
you make quite a team now are you
talking about bulletproof blind ninja
whatever it is you are classy
[Music]
come
[Music]
you'd be
[Music]
you think the four of you can save New
York you can't even save yourselves
[Music]
[Music]